[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my marvel new mutants
movie review that is right i had a
chance to see an actual movie
in a theater of sorts it was a drive-in
theater so i'll explain what that was
like
but no joke i was actually able to see
the new mutants movie
amidst all the release dates that we've
got in the past couple of years
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
do a new amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and let
me know in the comments where you want
to see these characters come back
in a new marvel mcu movie during marvel
phase 4 marvel phase 5.
what i'm going to do in this video is
i'll start with the non-spoilery part
and then i'll give a spoiler warning
later in the video when i talk about
more specific things about the ending of
the movie
and i know some of you will ask me so i
will rank this compared to some of the
other
last big x-men movies towards the end of
the video
overall it was a much smaller horror
version of a marvel
x-men movie so don't go into it
expecting the same thing that you would
expect from a mainstream giant 150
million dollar marvel mcu
or x-men or even avengers movie it's
more of a mid-budget
logan wolverine style movie but you've
posted all the memes about all the
release dates they even started to make
fun of themselves
would this movie ever get to see the
light of day finally they just decided
that
screw the virus we're gonna release it
no matter what the box office is
so i went to see it at a drive-in
theater it was perfectly safe i didn't
feel like there were any issues with
that the experience was fun
i'd never actually been to a drive-in
movie before i listened to the audio
from the movie on my car
speakers so even though that was a
little bit weird all the music the
dialogue
all the sound design the jump scares
everything still worked just fine the
speakers in my car were pretty
normal but we could spend an entire
video just talking about the history of
this movie and how it eventually wound
up on screen
but it is one of marvel's first horror
movies in general in the first horror
x-men movie that i can think of even
though there's some horrific elements
in other marvel movies but as i talk
about the movie you'll start to notice
that there are various points through
the film where it's not quite sure
whether or not it wants to be a horror
film
or if it wants to be a more mainstream
x-men film josh boone the director
pitched the movie as a rubber
reality mixture of one flew over the
cuckoo's nest meets a nightmare on elm
street with a bunch of characters not
being sure what is real being trapped in
this asylum
what's happening in our minds what's
happening in the real world but because
this is a comic book x-men marvel movie
the metaphorical terrors of their
psychic space
their minds also become real things in
the real world they have to face
the movie paints its themes in very
broad strokes and is very easy to follow
which was kind of disappointing for me
usually i like a more complex
film like i'm thinking more christopher
nolan's tenant which you kind of need a
bunch of graphs and charts to be able to
follow
it's only 90 minutes long which is very
very short for a marvel movie and even
though the director avoided a total
reshoot situation and fox trying to
overhaul the movie completely
there is still a lot of x-men marvel
movie crossover elements connecting the
movie to other big marvel movies
i don't want to get into too many big
spoilers about that in the video i will
do a separate video for the ending
the marvel phase four of it all and how
they're gonna handle these characters
inside the mcu
now that marvel has control of all the
x-men fantastic four characters
but overall i just gave the story of the
movie a passing grade it's a solid setup
they're putting the team together for
the first time and the movie was
originally intended to set up a trilogy
we actually know what the story is for
that entire trilogy now that the
director's come out and told us because
he doesn't think that he's going to be
able to make the other films
but the story of the movie is based on
the very first new mutants comic book
story the demon bear
saga in that danny moonstar is trying to
defeat demon bear a very powerful mutant
that killed her parents in most of her
tribe
the movie makes a lot of changes to
their comic book backstories of the
characters i didn't mind some of the
changes given the circumstances around
the making of the movie
in the overall current state of the fox
x-men marvel movie universe i know we're
all kind of hoping that deadpool 3
is gonna be titled deadpool kills the
fox marvel universe
and that's how they handle all that
continuity in the mcu going forward
but i have to say one of my biggest
issues with the movie is that danny
moonstar
is the main protagonist the pov
character that you follow through the
whole movie
she opens the film she ends the film but
she's arguably the least
interesting character in it probably the
shining star to come out of all this
is magic played by anna taylor joy she
did a great job
performing her character and her
character is written really well too
all the actors did great jobs with their
characters in general i'll talk about
them in more detail in a second
but just danny moonstar by herself as a
character felt underwritten
and her arc felt more like a cw version
of an x-men character arc
she even narrates the opening of the
movie and narrates the ending like they
do
on cw tv shows and it's not a spoiler to
say that they also used some buffy the
vampire slayer tv show clips in the
movie at various points just a comment
on what the action of the movie is
in that show aired on the network that
became the cw
but magic was great in the movie like i
said probably one of the standout
stars that they absolutely have to bring
back in the future
mcu marvel movies at some point now you
understand why so many of the trailers
that they release
focus on her scenes her powers and the
big record drop moments involving her
the way she's written and performed
though by anna taylor joy it almost
feels like magic is in a completely
different movie from all the other
characters
in the movie probably should have been
about her even her backstory as they
explain it during the movie is way more
compelling than danny moonstar's
backstory
that also gets into a lot of the
crossover elements the easter eggs for
other big x-men
and mcu marvel movies that they have in
there maisie williams was great as
wolfsbane she plays her as scottish so
it was kind of funny listening to her
deliver all of her dialogue with a
scottish broog
she also had one of the more compelling
story arcs in the movie too
they actually filmed this movie way back
between game of thrones season 6
and season 7 so we're talking a long
time ago
but even though all the other actors
look way older now
somehow she still seems exactly the same
like she does not age
at all pretty sure just like magic
maisie williams also said that she'd
love to come back in future marvel
movies
but charlie heaton was also pretty
decent as cannonball most of you will
know him from stranger things i do think
he's generally better
in the work that he does on stranger
things than he was in this movie he
plays his character with a strange
southern american accent it didn't
bother me that much but it just felt
like it wasn't absolutely necessary for
his character
the way they visualize his powers and
the special effects are really cool
though
sunspot was okay i hadn't seen the actor
playing him in anything before so i
didn't really have any expectations for
him
but based on what the director said they
just wanted his character to be this
spoiled douchey rich kid when the movie
begins who slowly matures as the team
comes together
and as written i thought he did a pretty
decent job with that
because roberto decosta has bigger ties
his father to the hellfire club his
character would have been much bigger in
the sequels had they done them there was
a deleted post-credit scene involving
his father in the hellfire club that
would have helped set up all that stuff
but i'll talk about that in more detail
in a separate video just because it is
kind of spoilery
alice braga was great as celia reyes
she's the nurse
ratchet of the movie for talking about
one flew over the cuckoo's nest
metaphors
they did a really good job writing her
as a very complex character she's not
necessarily a villain during the film
per se but they do use her character to
tie together some of the larger
x-men marvel movie easter eggs and big
post credit scenes from other big movies
so i will talk about that in my easter
egg video
you also probably just saw her in james
gunn's the suicide squad trailer just
this past weekend
i've already done a video for that too
playing a dc character no less
the movie is coming out next year so it
is funny to see actors jumping back and
forth between the marvel
and dc universe david dasmartian from
ant-man and the wasp
is also in that same suicide squad movie
as polka dot man
overall the special effects the sound
design the score were all pretty decent
even though i was listening to the audio
like i said through my car's speakers it
didn't lose any of its quality it was a
good experience
and the audio is a really really
important part of the overall movie
going experience
but one of the major things about the
movie that just did not work for me at
all
was the ending the way they tie things
off with danny moonstar's arc because
she is the main character
just feels like something right out of a
cw tv show
and it kind of made the movie feel like
an expensive episode of tv
more than an actual movie so just
careful for spoilers spoiler warning
we'll get into more specific details and
some of the issues that i have with the
film
so i felt like the whole demon bear arc
was super
underwritten and i did not like how they
changed it making him more of a
metaphorical villain quote-unquote than
an actual full-blown x-men comic book
villain
like the whole message of the movie is
to not let your fear control you
and they kind of beat you in the face
with that at various points in the film
instead of demon bear being this crazy
cosmic mutant
bent on destroying danny moonstar he's
just a psychic
projection of her own fears that she
then pats on the head like he's a good
boy
and proceeds to just wish him away like
i won't let my fear control me
so that was just a little too much for
me it didn't completely ruin the movie
for me or anything like that
i think the movie would have fared a lot
better if they would have committed
to the horror element and just done it
as an r rated film and
leaned into all the really scary stuff
because most of the time it felt like it
was bouncing back and forth between
mainstream x-men film traditional pg-13
for family audiences
and then a couple of scares that weren't
really that scary so it kind of failed
as a horror film but overall the movie
did feel like a very enjoyable
rental movie so this would have been a
perfect vod
release so my other really big complaint
about this is the fact that fox
let it sit on a shelf for a long time
there were some people inside fox that
wanted to completely reshoot the entire
film
thinking that the cost would be worth it
because the budget was so low compared
to the budget of the mainstream x-men
films
like them throwing away 50 60 million
dollars was no big deal
so when you hear people say that the
movie feels like it comes from a
different
era of comic book movies and even x-men
marvel movies
that's why because the movie was made
years ago when that was all happening
and it does feel very weird that it is
the very last
fox x-men marvel movie really that
should have wound up being the logan
movie
ringing this was some of the other more
recent x-men movies i would say it's
definitely better than x-men dark
phoenix i wasn't nearly as disappointed
coming out of this as i was of x-men
dark phoenix just because i had so many
big expectations
for a dark phoenix storyline i always
went into this movie
knowing that it would be a really small
thriller horror film
but given the current state of the world
and the fact that most movie theaters
are closed it was
a lot of fun to go to the drive-in and
see a movie like this
so it totally works as a drive-in movie
and hopefully they'll release it pretty
quickly
video on demand sometime in the next
month or two i don't know how long they
plan on leaving it in theaters
so what'll happen is is my video on the
ending the easter eggs post credit scene
marvel phase 4 x-men stuff
will happen probably sometime this
weekend as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see
that video when i post it
once you do have a chance to see the
movie just let me know what you think of
it in the comments below
overall like i said enjoyable movie but
just very mid-budget just don't have a
lot of expectations going into it
while you wait for everything everyone
click here to re-watch the batman
trailer with robert pattinson a billion
more times
and click here for my video on the new
spider-man 3 movie title reveal
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe we'll see you guys tonight